surprising story from sports business
daily that came out yesterday afternoon
the NFL has insisted that the regular
season schedule which usually is issued
before the draft would be out no later
than Saturday May 9 the network's were
bracing for it to land on the Thursday
may the seven now that the draft is over
which consumed so much focus from the
front office from the commissioner etc
now the draft is done the Commissioner
is giving it a fresh look guys because
there are factions in the league office
and also people within the ticket
industry specifically the resellers who
are saying hang on a second
we can't schedule these games because
once we start selling and reselling
tickets we put ourselves into a
potential mess if there aren't fans and
we don't know when game is going to be
able to be played and maybe we just need
a few more weeks to have a better
understanding of where everything is
going to be come September so all of a
sudden there's a debate and there's a
delay and there's a possibility that we
will not have a schedule by May 9 that
is now up in the air but you know for a
league that has managed to avoid
significant tangible negative impacts of
the corona virus pandemic this one could
be the biggest one yeah the off season
programs are going to happen but ok but
but this delaying the schedule deeper
into May and who knows how long after
that that really to me is a sign that
this situation has gotten the NFL's
attention Peter and maybe they want to
do some more planning for contingencies
before they actually pull the sheet off
of the schedule well Mike I'm fairly
convinced I've hinted at this in my
column but I'm fairly convinced now that
the NFL is not only making contingency
schedules if they have to play 12 games
14 games you know because you know as
I've said the NFL could play a 12 game
schedule with no byes and start on
October 18th and keep the schedule
exactly on course as to what it was but
I believe the NFL is doing something
else I believe that they are also
creating a schedule that
that could start later that could start
let's say four weeks later and then
could push the Superbowl three or four
weeks later depending on what if they
have a bi and all that and I think
that's the one thing we should be
focused on the fact that if the NFL is
determined to play a 16-game schedule
there's no reason why they can't play
the Superbowl at the end of February
instead of at the beginning of February
yeah it's very interesting you know
first off I don't know how you you know
I agree I mean with the NFL here you got
to delay the schedule release you can't
set out anything concrete right now as
the end of April you know again there's
just too much unknown in our world right
now and what's going on with this virus
and where it's gonna go and all those
other issues have to be ironed out
before I think you can start worrying
about you know the particular details of
an NFL schedule and you know I can't
imagine it seems like we're gonna have
to get through the month of May at least
here to have a little bit better picture
of which way our culture and
civilization just in general is gonna go
here throughout the summer into the
early fall so I you know again I know
and you know I know Mike we've been
privy to information of course Peter is
too because Peter knows everybody but
the NFL is coming up with a lot of
different contingency plans and I'll go
again to the tomb you know something
I've been saying I just don't think you
know and the evidence again this weekend
I don't think as many NFL people is
concerned with this virus as the rest of
the world we just saw football players I
know want to just play football they
don't care and I understand that I said
that to Mike before if I was 26 years
old back in my prime I'd have been
sitting there going okay I'm not worried
about this cope in 19 just want to play
football I'll stay away from my mom and
my dad and my grandma and grandpa so I
won't get them sick or do anything like
that but I want to play football and I
think there is an overwhelming calling
for that throughout the NFL even with
coaches in the front office you know so
I'm just interested to see where it goes
but I totally understand them delaying
the schedule release would the unknowns
of the world right now the key is coming
up with a clear strategy for who gets to
how often they get tested where they go
when the workday ends where they can
potentially be right posed or exposed
for the first time and then test them
again the testing is going to be the key
and this is a point that the Morris
Smith the NFLPA executive director makes
very very astutely and I think so far it
has been overlooked by fans and by the
media the idea and this was mentioned by
dr. Anthony Falchi in comments to the
new york times without widespread
testing it's not gonna work and you
can't have sports hog all the testing
right now we continue to be and this is
one of the things that is the most
mind-boggling to me about the entire pan
mind-boggling not have enough tests so
how can you Peter how can you have all
of the testing that the NFL would need
of all the players all the coaches all
the trainers anybody who walks into that
petri dish that is a locker room how can
you have testing for them as often as
you need it when the general public
doesn't have access to it that is to me
the biggest impediment to getting the
football season on track and until they
solve that it's going to be hard to
implement any of these plans I've been
saying exactly that for the last week or
10 days the only way the NFL can play
the games the only way that that the
NFLPA will allow the membership to play
games is if they do enough testing so
that they know whether every person who
sets foot on a field whether there are
fans there or not every person who sets
foot on a field medical people players
coaches staff whatever it takes and mike
let's just say that there are you know
200 people in an organization that would
be necessary to the functioning of an
organization to play a game let's just
I'm inventing that I don't know what it
is it might be a hundred and fifty but
let's just say it's 200 you're gonna
have to test those people at least twice
a week okay and you're gonna have to get
the test back same day obviously so if
you testing those guys in doing it every
week then that means that each team in
the NFL is taking up a 400 tests per
week
on average okay and then if you multiply
that times 32 teams basically then what
you're getting is a Monstress number of
tests and the NFL is going to have to
answer to the people who say hey wait a
second
states can't get enough tests we can't
get enough to these people can't get
enough tests and the only way the NFL
will be able to do it Mike I believe is
if Donald Trump or whoever is going to
be in charge of this Anthony foul gee
this says okay we give you special
dispensation all right to go out
independently and purchase from some lab
in China whatever it is 50000 tests to
use during the season so that every NFL
team will be able to play games and I
don't know 50 or a hundred thousand that
is the only way it can happen and if
they can't get that dispensation I don't
know what the NFL is gonna do yeah and
Dee Smith is the only one within the NFL
bubble that has articulated that thought
and it could be that others have not
because they don't like where that trail
of logic ultimately leads because it is
going to take something Herculean like
that and there's still going to be a
glaring disparity between the NFL and
the rest of the public that desperately
needs the testing as well
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports